everything around you  is  incredible if you're willing to look at  it that way everything around you can be  taken for granted if that's your  perspective  but it really is about the frame that  you choose to put around things i mean  simply being alive is already insane the  odds are so stacked against you not only  just being a human but being a human at  this  moment in time this moment in time where  breakthroughs and technology are  happening at  at an unprecedented rate where  breakthroughs in medical science are  happening at an unprecedented rate where  our ability to connect with people to  empathize with people all the way around  the globe all of the changes that have  happened in technology and telecom and  connectivity health everything  we're living in  the most miraculous time ever  but you have to look at it that way